mysteries come in all shapes sizes and
locations it is fascinating and every
every project that we do is different
david conlon is an archaeologist with
the department of interior what he has
found in the depths of lake mead is
fascinating this is our first real
serious look at what's going on here
near hemingway harbor kotlin has
uncovered the remains of an aggregate
plant a facility used in the 1930s to
make concrete to build hoover dam this
is underwater video of the site the
submarine right here provides all the
pictures it really is an ingenious
little device you have lights right here
a camera in front and propellers up top
and in the back that allow the submarine
to go forward or backward up or down
this is such an incredible piece of
history kay rhodey is a park service
educator at lake mead she always knew
the concrete plant was down there
somewhere in the water but when she saw
video of an intact railroad even she was
surprised to actually see the rails down
there
all of a sudden it was very real and
everywhere we look there's remains of of
nevada's history throughout the weekend
david conlan will guide the submarine
throughout hemingway harbor to see what
other secrets lake mead might be hiding
brian allen channel 8 eyewitness news